alabama's josh jacobs was the first
running back taken in the draft this
year the only first rounder and the
oakland raiders have big plans
for the rookie jacobs says that coach
john gruden has told him the team
expects him to win
offensive rookie of the year
look i i always
err toward a running back when figuring
out the candidates for rookie of the
year chris because they get the most
opportunities to touch the football and
do something spectacular and they can
come in right away and make an impact
that's just a tall order to put on a guy
if you're john gruden but it doesn't
really surprise me based upon the
stories you've told about gruden he
probably likes to put a lot of pressure
on guys and see how they deal with it he
does and you know i think that with a
guy like josh jacobs first of all this
is this is john gruden's version of
alvin kamara and i think when i when i
evaluated josh jacobs coming out of
alabama i thought he was a better
version of alvin kamara and i'm sure
john gruden's showing them old roger
craig highlights with the 49ers and
charlie garner highlights with the
eagles and my tampa bay buccaneers and
cadillac williams he does all that stuff
to try to motivate the guy but there
will be a huge package within this
offense mike for josh jacobs not only in
the run game but the pass game as well
and yeah you said it i think he's gonna
have the touches to be in that
conversation because of the position and
because of the offense
yeah and look this is exactly why
ezekiel elliot is holding out because
running backs get chewed up and spit out
from the moment they walk through the
door yeah when you are paying the guy
peanuts in comparison to what the best
running backs get they are churning up
the yardage catching the passes and
possibly winning rookie of the year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports